we were hearing earlier in the show
about how research has suggested that
there could be a significant gap between
people's perceptions of climate change
and the severity of the climate
emergency so are we taking the climate
crisis seriously enough uh emily let's
come to you first there's definitely
been an improvement of awareness hasn't
there but still a significant number of
climate deniers in g7 countries
uh yes which when we see the the changes
that are occurring around the world in
terms of the extreme weather events that
we that you that you highlighted earlier
in the program is quite shocking here in
the uk um a recent survey showed that
actually british adults do really um
appreciate the scale of the threat the
environmental threat threat and and rank
it as being one of the top three issues
facing the country today above brexit
immigration crime and other important
issues um but but nevertheless is the
case that we you know there are still a
significant number of people who don't
appreciate the scale of
of the crisis that we're facing in terms
of climate change
it also looked in terms of how people
are feeling and looked in terms of the
level of optimism that people were
feeling we can see that uh here this
quote and how how it easily can slip
over into feeling uh delusional about
things and when you read the ipcc report
dan that came out this summer
which suggested it could take millennia
to repair the damage that we've done
is it right that people the significant
proportion of people are optimistic that
they can fix it in their lifetime
well i'm in the solutions industry and
even when i read that report it made my
kind of jaw uh drop and realize the
science of the challenge but there are
lots of things that we can do and i
remain actually very very optimistic
the last year and a half people have
really really started to take notice of
this issue it has changed and it is
something that is being debated there
are some people who won't take notice
for many years still to come but we
don't have to focus necessarily on them
we focus on the people that we can win
over and there's lots of great new
technologies that people can employ to
lower their carbon emissions yeah i mean
that's another interesting thing isn't
it emily a lot of people that were
surveyed said yeah i'm gonna do this but
the number of people who actually did it
was much lower
yeah well i mean just to go back to your
earlier i'm a climate scientist and um
so i spent time in the
and the
antarctic and i've seen the scale of the
change as that are occurring there and
you know it's quite right the people are
pessimistic but at the same time i'm
also i'm very much part of helping
develop some of the solutions and where
i am optimistic it's in terms of the the
exciting innovations and creativity in
terms of um how we can generate
solutions that actually have all sorts
of other benefits as well um benefits in
terms of improving air quality for
example going back to um just the start
of this segment um so i think you know
pessimism and optimism is is a mixture
of the two
and dan from your perspective what is
the role of business not just big
business but small business in all of
this
well i think i think business does have
a big role to play i think we need to
cut to the chase now the reality is that
this problem's been around for a very
long time people are really interested
in solutions but don't necessarily know
where to begin so i think for example
one of the things that i talk about a
lot every day is is electric cars and
we believe that they are one of the
biggest solutions to uh dealing with
this problem not the only one by any
means but things like businesses taking
that seriously and having charging
points outside their their properties is
a good start so businesses can play a
huge role by accepting the reality of
what's going on actually
leading from the front and employees
will
take comfort and that will follow their
lead all right so lots for us to work
with there but still some room to
improve
you